As the father of four daughters and
hearing a missile hit a school, if it's
true, everyone should apologize. Like,
look, we can figure out who did it
later. This is a result of our conflict.
Are you confident that you'll be proven
right that Iran ultimately will prevail
in this war?
>> Once the United States sends in ground
forces, there's no turning back. It's
all in. It'll be another Vietnam.
>> We're going to kill all the bad guys and
we're going to replace them with the
good guys. is it's like a foreign
policy, you know, made up by elementary
school students. It's it's embarrassing.
>> Is Israel is a more secure place? Is the
United States stronger today than 2
weeks ago? Is the world a better place
today than two weeks ago? For God's
sake, I feel good about where we're
going as a nation. We're killing all the
right people and we're cutting your
taxes.
>> I haven't held the excitement that
Senator Graham has. He's he's never met
a war that he doesn't love and he just
gets giddy excited like a guy who's
going to make a bunch of money when we
bomb a bunch of people cuz well that's
what he does.
President Bush famously landed on the
USS Abraham Lincoln to declare mission
accomplished in the Iraq war just weeks
after the invasion began. As we all now
know that war lasted another eight
years. Bush had won a second term and
eventually retired by the time the last
troops returned to the US. Few believe
the mission was ever accomplished and
the whole war on terror became a
cautionary tale about Middle Eastern
quagmires and a cornerstone of the MAGA
revulsion to war. Supporters of this war
think it's time to move on from the
ghost of Iraq and that it has no lessons
for the current conflict. A position
summed up emphatically last night by
President Trump.
And as we take decisive action to stop
the threat posed by the terrorist regime
in Iran with Operation Epic Fury.
Is that a great name?
Well, it's only good if you win. You
know, you can only do and we've won. Let
me tell you, we've won. You know, you
never like to say too early you won. We
won.
Well, if the war was won in the first
hour, the substance of the victory is
yet to become clear. The IDF says Israel
is under Iranian fire as we speak. Cargo
ships and oil containers are under
attack across the region, sending oil
prices into orbit again. The new
Ayatollah has doubled down with a
message of vengeance in his first public
statement, albeit nobody's actually seen
him yet. And there are claims he's
incapacitated. Amid all of this, the
fact is that victory for Iran is quite
simple. If the regime survives with its
autonomy, Iran will claim victory.
Victory for the United States and Israel
is a lot more complicated. Many roads do
seem to lead to a new Iran, which is a
lot like the old Iran, but even more
aggressive. It could be subdued,
possibly for months or even years, but
with a greater incentive than ever, to
arm itself and attack. That's why people
are legitimately worried about a long
and deadly conflict. And that's why
people, let's turn to Lindsey Graham,
who has threatened everywhere from
Lebanon to Spain in the last week, are
working overtime to sell the benefits of
war.
>> We're going to blow the hell out of
these people. This regime is in a death
row now. It is going to be on its knees.
It's going to fall. And when it falls,
we're going to have peace like no other
time. We're going to have prosperity
unlike anyone could ever imagine. Peace.
Well, the problem with this kind of
gleeful rhetoric about blowing the hell
out of these people is that many of
these people are innocent civilians. US
media is reporting today that US
military investigators believe American
forces were responsible for the deadly
strike on an Iranian primary school
that's believed to have killed over 100
children. It looks a lot like a tragic
accident on an enormous scale. If
President Trump and his administration
want to build public support for this
war, they should very quickly face up to
it and apologize. and they should very
quickly tell Lindsey Graham to
respectively keep his mouth shut. Well,
to debate this, I'm joined by Robert
Neil, the former US Navy Seal, by Gideon
Levy, the Israeli author, journalist,
and commentator at Herets, Republican
Cory Mills, the Florida congressman, and
US Army veteran, and Ryan Grim, Breaking
Points co-host, and investigative
journalist with the Drop Site News.
Well, welcome to all of you. Uh, Robert
O'Neal, welcome back again to
Uncensored. A few people have had more
experience of combat in the Middle East
than you and of course you killed Osama
bin Laden. Um so I just want to ask you
from a pure military perspective, it
seems to me that you know the American
military might coupled with the Israeli
military might uh has proved pretty
overwhelming from a pure military
perspective against Iran's military. but
that the way that Iran is conducting its
tactical war in terms of going after
economic damage uh may be much more
difficult to defeat. Would that be your
reading?
>> It's going to be difficult to defeat
that. Yes. And thanks for having me
back, Peters. Yeah, the uh we're going
to defeat them militarily, and we've
proven that everywhere we go militarily,
and that's just what we do. We've got a
very strong group of men and women that
can do that. Uh, I, you know, I was
there for the invasion 2003. I remember
the buildup. I remember I was excited at
the time because it's just right after
911 and as a young Navy, young Navy
Seal, especially at Seal Team Six, I
want to invade anywhere. U, I I haven't
held the excitement that Senator Graham
has. He's he's never met a war that he
doesn't love and he just gets giddy
excited like a guy who's going to make a
bunch of money when we bomb a bunch of
people because, well, that's what he
does. And they get amped about that. But
for me, it's like, yes, we can beat him,
but what do we do next? I know Donald
Trump doesn't want to go in there and
try to do a regime change, but
eventually something has to happen. If
boots on the ground means taking
inspectors in with guys with guns, so be
it. We do have guys at the tier one
level with the designation to take out
military sites and inspect them, maybe.
But again, like your previous guest was
saying, you get boots on the ground,
that's what the I hate the word
quagmire, but I mean, if it if the shoe
fits, right? We don't want to get back
in that. The Iranian people, yeah, they
wanted us, but so did parts of the Iraqi
people. So does everybody. But
eventually, regardless of uh your
intentions, if you spend time there,
you're an occupier. And people, even if
they're on their side, the longer you
bomb them, the less they're going to
like you. And I think I I've I've never
been hit with an American bomb, but I
think the the most terrifying thing
possible is be in a building that's hit.
The best thing that could happen is you
die right away, but you'll probably just
be under there under rubble, burning for
a long, long time, suffocating. Maybe
horrible stuff. This is not something to
cheer. This is war is the should be the
very end of a political means. Uh I've
been to war a lot. I'm not pro-war. I
think there should be other ways to do
it. I'm watching cautiously and I'm
hoping um you know I I don't ever
consider myself the smartest man in the
room. I hope I'm hoping the smartest man
in the room more men and women do show
up. I'm willing to listen. I'm willing
to learn and what we've done in the past
has worked and it hasn't worked. So uh
it doesn't matter why we're here. We
just are. So hopefully levelheads can
prevail, right?
And Rob, how do you feel given all your
experience? How do you feel about some
of the more inflammatory rhetoric that
we're hearing from people like Pete
Hegith in particular, coupled with the
way that the official White House social
media accounts are pumping out kind of
movie style promos about this war?
Almost like this is not real. This is
like a movie we're watching. I got to
say, as someone who's had a lot of
family myself who've gone to combat in
war, I don't like it. It's like it's not
how most people talk about it.
>> I I I don't like it. War is a lot
different than what a lot of the public
sees in video games and uh TV shows. You
do not respond respond, excuse me. And
when bullets fly this way, uh there's a
moment of pause because they only need
to be right once. And when something
blows up, if you die, you're just dead.
Um, you I mean you do need propaganda to
build up morale, but movie stuff like
that, I don't I don't like it. Um,
however, now with Pete Hexath, I was
advocating for a mid-grade officer with
combat experience to take the Pentagon,
and he did. And uh, I'm all in with Pete
Hexath. This is what we needed. I like
the way he does it. I like the way he
works out with the troops and has a
morale high. The media doesn't like him.
I mean, most of the the the media that
says he's doing a good job generally
because, let's be honest, they they
don't want him to succeed. I like what
he's doing. I don't like a lot of the
rhetoric, but some of it has to happen,
some of it doesn't have to happen, but
uh you know, you got to stay the course.
Mission front front side focus and after
you hit them, if possible, get out.
>> Okay, let's go to uh Congressman Mills.
First of all, I want to talk about this
attack on the girls school, which now
looks increasingly likely, according to
the New York Times and other reports,
that this was an American missile strike
that had gone wrong. some suggestion
that there was in intelligence from the
Israelis which turned out to be false.
It was of course next to uh a
revolutionary guard base and used to be
part of the base and then was moved and
it may be. This was just a horrific
accident but it had enormous
consequences. Uh would it not be the
right thing, the morally right thing if
it was the United States, and they must
know by now if it was one of their
planes or one of their missiles that if
it was the United States, they just hold
their hands up and say, "We made a
terrible mistake and we're terribly
sorry."
>> Well, I think the biggest thing, and
thanks for having me on, Pierce, it's
great to be on this panel. Rob I've got
a tremendous amount of respect for. He's
uh a true decorated hero and I'm
grateful to be on this panel. But, you
know, I want to say that one of the
things you don't do, whether it's in
politics or the military, is get out
ahead of intel. You know, we want to
make sure that we get the actual post
blast analysis. We want to look at what
the actual trajectory of whatever that
tomahawk or whatever that missile was to
ensure that we know what the actual
impact radius was, where it actually was
intended to hit, what that target
actually was or was not. Um, and then if
we do determine that it is something
that is uh a US uh uh strike or a US
missile or whatever the case may be,
then we look at what was the actual
cautionary reasons of why it occurred.
So uh you know until I get into the
actual skiff and get an intel brief on
this, you know, I sit on the armed
services committee. I sit on a
subcommittee of military personnel on
military readiness and the intelligence
special operations. Uh I'm the
subcommittee chair of the oversight and
intelligence for foreign affairs
committee. So until I can actually get
in there, I'm not going to get over my
skis and start making comments, but I
can tell you that if and you know when
this is determined, if the United States
is is respondable anyway, it'll take its
accountability. It'll do its afteraction
review. We did this in Iraq. We did this
in Afghanistan. And every conflict and
uh as Rob and others will tell you in
any operation, no matter how great it
is, you always do an AR to determine how
we can get better.
And in terms of the mission itself,
we've we've heard now myriad different
uh explanations for what the mission is
and what victory looks like. What is
your understanding of what victory looks
like? Because as I said to Rob, there's
no doubt that uh in terms of military
firepower, the United States and Israeli
combined firepower is clearly causing
enormous damage to Iran's military. But
it's also true that the closure of the
straight of Homa is pretty well
completely closed. If that goes on for
much longer, the uh the enormous damage
that is causing to the global economy,
coupled with the attacks they've been
making on all the neighboring Gulf
States, trying to clearly intimidate uh
tourists from going there, which is the
new business model for many of those
states. You know, this could be
incredibly damaging uh and makes the
word victory look a little bit more
complex.
>> Well, war is always complex, especially
when you talk about geopolitical
analytics. I mean, look at the fact that
China, Russia, Iran, and North Korea,
this access of evil have been
geopolitically lined for a while. Their
goal from the very beginning, whether
you talk about the belt and road
initiative, whether you talk about the
funding of Iranian proxy militias, was
always to eliminate the US dollar's
global currency. Not to mention the fact
that China had a lot at stake on this.
What they wanted to do with the belt and
road initiative is have Russia start the
war in Ukraine to expand the Eurasian
border, take over Oceanania, take the 15
of 16 rare earth mineral mines of
Africa, which now cuts off the Vorn of
Africa, Persian Gulf, Red Sea, Black
Sea. This is now an actual isolation
move while in the western hemisphere
utilizing economic coercion on Panama
and Honduras to control tax tariffs and
transit to guarantee that while they're
buying up our farmlands, while they're
buying up men translations, as people in
the Navy will tell you, how long can a
nuclear submarine stay underwater until
it runs out of food? That was the intent
from the beginning was always economic
warfare by China. We've been in war with
China and Russia for 20 plus years. It's
just that we kept calling them a great
superpower resurgence. When it comes to
the designation of this conflict or this
hostility, let's go back to the 2011
Obama days where Libya was actually
utilizing the Department of Justice's UN
regulations to quantify it as being able
to go in and do these things if it was
in the needs of saving innocent
civilians. Well, I can tell you 40,000
plus innocent Iranians were dying in the
streets. There was human rights
atrocities like never before. We also
had imminent threat with regards to
knowing that the Eshan, the Forom, and
the Natan's facilities, they were
destroyed. But at what levels do we are
we guaranteeing this? We knew they had
the Shahed 136s, which are a very
effective drone that's being utilized
today that we now have our own Lucas
system, which is about a $35,000 program
for Operation Scorpion Strike. But it
was all about eliminating the IRGC's
capabilities of imminent strike with the
with the ICBMs. And guess what else we
found out? We found out they had working
hypersonic ballistic missiles. These are
ballistic missiles that traveled over
15,000 plus miles per hour and have the
ability to hit mock levels that we can't
actually be 100% effective on. So
there's a lot of things that came into
this. One, it was guaranteeing that
innocent civilians weren't continuing to
be killed. two, stopping imminent threat
of actual nuclear capabilities because
we know that under the JCPOA under
resolution 2231 that both Bong Kimmoon
and Gutierrez who are the general
secretary of the UN said that the U Iran
was in direct violation sending
mid-range long-range ballistic missiles
to the Houthis and others and enriching
well past the 70% mark. Now I want to be
clear 70% is over the threshold but to
get from 70 to nuclear grade it's a flip
of the switch. That's how easy it
actually is. So denigrate the IRGC,
eliminate the head of the snake, which
is the Ayatollah, which we know there's
multiple heads. Rob and I can tell you
that you eliminate one terrorist
organization. Let's say it's Kazumsmani.
You get Ishmael Ghani, you eliminate uh
you know, one terrorist Europe, they get
another. But my point is is that we are
moving in the right direction of
military coordinated strikes,
guaranteeing that imminent threats are
gone, guaranteeing that regional
securities are provided, then usher in
someone like Reslavi who can actually be
a transitional governor who doesn't want
to stay in power. or he wants to be
voted at the ballot box and now we
actually have a transitional plan. This
is not Iraq. This is not Afghanistan.
>> Okay, I want to bring in the other the
other panelists. Uh I don't want to cut
you off. Uh Congressman, I do want to
bring in the other
>> very complex. I guess I saw you.
>> Sorry.
>> I say it's just very complex, Pierce, to
get into a 30 secondond segment.
>> No, no. I listen I totally respect that.
But we have got obviously got four
panelists. I want to bring in uh Ryan
Grim because I could see you reacting to
some of the things you were hearing
there. Um I mean The congressman makes
it sound relatively straightforward. The
mission is going very well. The uh the
stuff that they wanted to achieve is
being achieved and it won't be long
before Rever Palavi is in the middle of
Tehran leading the brave new world. What
do you think of that?
>> It's it's just completely absurd. It's
it's like a we're going to kill all the
bad guys and we're going to replace them
with the good guys. It's like a foreign
policy, you know, made up by elementary
school students when in fact it is a
foreign policy student that is targeting
and killing elementary school students.
That's what it's doing in in the real
world in this like fantasy land. You're
like, "Oh, get this bad guy. Get this
bad guy. Get this bad guy." And oh, Rea
Reesa over here who lives in PTOIC,
Maryland. We're going to like ship him
over to Iran and he's going to be the
new king of Iran. Like, it's it's
embarrassing.
And what about the mission itself in
terms of the changing positions? And I
thought, and I'll come to Gideon about
this in a moment, but it was very
telling to me that it looked like the
mask slightly slipped when Marco Rubio
uh said, "Well, the the need to attack
preemptively from the United States was
because they have been told somebody
else, clearly Israel, was about to
attack Iran and that Iran would then
respond likely against American bases
and that because of that, America had to
get in first." Uh, and then of course
they tried to wind that back. I don't
think Marco Rubio misspoke. I just think
they didn't appreciate quite how that
was going to play out.
>> Right. And and because we haven't gotten
a a rationale that they have stuck to,
initially it was the nuclear program,
then it was regime change. We've now
been told that neither of those are
actually objectives of the war anymore.
Dropsite uh put out a poll in into the
field over the last weekend asking the
American public why do you think the US
went into this war 50% of the country
believes now that Donald Trump at least
in part went to war against Iran in
order to distract from the Jeffrey
Epstein scandal. So by a 50 to 41 margin
that's what the American public believes
likely voters. Uh we we also asked about
the influence of Israel. uh nearly 50% I
think 46% of likely voters said that
they believed that Trump was more
responsive when it came to the war in
Iran to Benjamin Netanyahu than he was
to the American public. The I think 47%
said he was more responsive to the
American people uh than to Benjamin
Netanyahu. So he's as almost 50% of that
he ran as America first. Not even 50% of
the country believes that he went to war
for the United States. We have never had
a president in the history of the United
States who went to a war of any sort,
let alone a war of this scale and had
nearly half the country believing,
whether it's true or not, believing that
he did it for a different country.
>> Or actually, Gideon Levy, there hasn't
been a war that I can remember in modern
times where there hasn't been a majority
support from the American people once it
started. And there isn't for this. Uh
it's an unpopular war. The majority of
Americans do not want America to be
waging this war. They're particularly
concerned because they've already got
still got inflation, still got rising
costs. They've seen prices at the gas
pump now rocketing in the last two
weeks. Uh this is the biggest uh turmoil
for oil prices in history that has
already happened in the first two weeks
and could get a hell of a lot worse. So
purely from that perspective, I think
Donald Trump politically has taken an
enormous gamble here. But in relation to
the role of Israel, you know, there is a
theory that Trump has been sort of
barreled into doing this by Benjamin
Netanyahu sort of wearing them down and
saying, "Look, we've got a window. The
Ayatollah is with all his top people
right now. We can take them all out and
it'll be a bit like Venezuela where you
take out the head and the rest follows."
and that having committed to that and
talked about quick regime change,
clearly that hasn't happened. In fact,
the Ayatollah's own son is reported to
be the new supreme lead, although we
haven't seen him. Um, and and coupled
with that, there's a sense that Israel
has a different objective here, that
Israel would be quite happy if this all
plunges Iran into total anarchic chaos.
um a bit like happened in Syria and that
that would suit uh Israel's longerterm
uh needs and wants which he kind of just
reduces it to uh anarchy whereas that
would not suit the United States. So
there could be two different uh sort of
missions here where Israel's quite happy
if this just drags on and on and on and
is a bit of a disaster. Um but the
United States would find that very very
difficult to manage. What are your
thoughts on that?
>> So, first of all, we are witnessing now
the backlashes of the 7th of October 23.
Ever since then, Israel turned into the
notion that everything can be solved and
everything is legitimate to be solved by
force and by a lot of force, by
unlimited force. We will change the
leadership of the Middle East. First, we
tried in Gaza. I must remind you two and
a half years no regime change in Gaza
even though it was a very clear goal
never achieved Hamas's life and kicking
and don't compare Gaza to Iran obviously
and now we went to this war again as the
first option as as as while totally
ignoring you know in this discussion
Pierce and thank you for having me again
in this discussion we hardly spoke about
other prices we Paul spoke about the
prices of oil and the economical price.
There are millions of people who were
displaced in the last two years by
Israel and now by the United States.
Most of them have no place to go back.
What about them? They are totally not in
this in this formula of comparing
utility and price. No, they must be
remembered. Now coming back to your
question Pierce, Israel went to this war
without having a very clear endgame.
They saw an opportunity. There was a the
stars
showed that Trump and Netanyahu get
along and would agree about such an
adventure, such a dangerous adventure,
and they went for it. I don't know who
convinced whom. It sounds more logical
that Netanyahu convinced
the American president even though he's
not someone to be so easily convinced.
But in any case, look at the outcome. Is
the world a better place today than two
weeks ago for God's sake? Is Israel is a
more secure place than two weeks ago? Is
the United States stronger today than
two weeks ago? Those are the questions
which are not asked. And I one more word
pierce with your permission. We were
speaking about the big criticism in
American public opinion about this war.
Surprise surprise 94% of the Israeli
Jews support this war. Can you believe
it? Those are people who pay a price for
this war. 94 those North Korean figures.
Only North Korea you get on any issue
94% support. Let's think also about
this. A state after two and a half
terrible war in Gaza wants another war.
What does it tell us about the Israeli
society?
Yeah. And of course, you know, Netanyahu
was in deep political peril after
October the 7th because people were
blaming him for allowing it to happen on
his watch. He was facing a corruption, a
criminal trial that's been put on the
back burner. He's seen his personal
popularity rising at the same rate that
he's been bombing places. And he's
probably doing the maths and working out
quite cynically because he can be very
cynical that the best way for his own
political preservation is to carry on
doing what he's doing, which is settling
all the schools. I mean, he he made it
clear that Iran was a 40-year uh project
for him, which was finally happening. Uh
Robert Neil, I know you've got to leave
us um imminently. Um,
as an American, putting aside your
amazing career in the military, but as
an American, given the state of the
economy, given the real time effect on
Americans at the at the pump with food
prices, there's still inflation, so
they've carried on going up. Given that
Donald Trump campaigned so viferously
that he wasn't going to take America
into any more wars, particularly in the
Middle East, and he was going to sort
out the economy and sort out the cost of
living, are you comfortable that he's
now launched the biggest war in the
Middle East imaginable and it's having
such a huge effect on the economy? He
says this is all a price worth paying.
Do you agree with that?
Uh I do in theory agree with it that if
it does work out the prices of
everything will go down because it will
positively affect um oil prices and that
that as we know affects everything. Uh
I'm not optim I mean I'm yeah I'm
optimistic but I don't I don't like
seeing this. I don't like going to war.
Uh I do I do know President Trump and I
know he loves his legacy and he cares
about his family and I think given the
intel that I'm not privy to I'm not in
the meetings either that he's gotten and
where he is. this is the way to go in
order to get the stability. Um, you
know, the whenever you get preemptive
strikes on people, it's it's it's hard
to say. I mean, we knew what Hitler was
doing in 1938. We didn't do anything.
President Buchanan and Pierce had
something to do. They didn't they
weren't aggressive with the South at the
time before they were mighty we had the
Civil War. Million people died. Uh,
preemptive strikes though, 2003. I went
to Iraq. Turns out it wasn't the way to
go. So, I mean, I'm very, very cautious
as a father of four daughters and
hearing a missile hit a school. If it's
true, everyone should apologize. Like,
look, we can figure out who did it
later. This is a result of our conflict
usually because men in political power
couldn't agree on something. That's what
we should say. And that unfortunately
with all the cheering aside and all the
cool movies, that's the end result on
the ground. That's the difference
between being there and seeing it on TV.
So, again, I'm I'm going to watch it.
But I want I I would love to see every
family in the world be successful and
pay lower gas prices. And I really I
really like I said I really do believe
do do believe this administration is
doing what they think is the right thing
for the future not just of the country
but of the West. Don't like war, hate
cheering for war, but I'm watching and
again I'm trying to stay open-minded. I
personally will do everything I can to
to help with world peace. I thought I
did before and here we are again.
>> Yeah. Um Congressman Mills, I mean
politically it's a massive stupendous
roll of the dice by Donald Trump. The
midterm elections are coming in
November. Historically, a president in
his position would normally probably
lose the House. That's expected to
happen. But now there's lots of
rumblings this may cost in the Senate,
which would basically leave him a
completely lame duck uh for the last two
years of his presidency. Uh and right
now he can keep saying this is all over,
we've won, and so on. But the reality on
the ground which we can all see with our
own eyes is very different. Are you
worried politically about this if it
carries on much longer?
>> Well, let me just go ahead and touch on
something and Rob had talked about it
and it's been severed like many times
about oil and economics. What we have to
understand is this. Just like I talked
about with that geopolitical alignment
that was after the dollar is a global
currency. It's not about the dollar, the
bot, the yen, the ruble, the the dinar.
It's always been about energy. Energy is
a global currency and what we knew is is
that you have the ability here to not
only eliminate an evil regime and stop
nuclear capabilities that could actually
threaten the west as well as for our
allies and ourselves but also to help
start getting a a stability solution
against all these Shia backed militias
who are being funded by this type of
illicit trade of oil to China. Now why
does this always look as an individual
thing? It's not. If you look at the
geopolitical ramifications of the
elimination of Maduro, that was 70% of
the oil that went to China. Iran is
another 20% that goes to China. That now
potentially stops the unification of
Taiwan or the threats across the
Taiwanese straight even though they are
building up the coastal defense
conscripts etc. But the same thing for
Russia. Russia's biggest supplier that
they had actual defense goods to was
actually Iran. So now you've actually
got an economic loss there as well. So
this is doing a lot of things for the
region. Not just eliminating this
regime, but it will actually bounce back
oil prices because we've always had
issues with Iran in the street of Hamus.
We've always had issues with the threats
of trying to go after things like with
the Houthies on Saudi Araco that had an
impact on the actual oil production. So
this is a momentary diversion as
Secretary of Energy Wright had said that
allows us to not only try and help to
free innocent civilians who are dying
but not get boots on the ground. This is
not Iraq and Afghanistan. We are not
nation building. We are not looking to
try and put in an implementation of
democrats. We're not trying to do an
article 76 of the '05 constitution to
set forth sectarian democracy which
hasn't existed in pre-apartid South
Africa or Northern Ireland. This is
about literally just trying to go good
versus evil, eliminate an evil threat,
guarantee stability in the region, stop
instant lives from being lost, stoping
nuclear power from coming into there,
and then also look at the economic
properties that will benefit the US as
well as for the globe.
>> Ryan Grim, your response to that?
Well, I mean, one of the economic
companies that would benefit is the
congressman's. Congressman, you correct
me if I'm wrong. You you you're an arms
trafficker. No,
>> no, I'm not actually. I don't actually
own a company and I actually have
divested on blind trust. I'm also the
only member of Congress who actually
donates 100% of my salary to
>> divested into a blind trust. That's
those are those are contradictory terms.
D if you divested, you don't own it
anymore.
>> Ready to go in.
>> Do you own the do you own an arms
trafficking company? Look, I don't
actually. That's the funniest part. We
actually train our law enforcement and
military and our police on how to do
less lethals and how to help with
federal bureau of prisons, how to help
with our law enforcement departments and
riot control in Minneapolis, New York,
the blue cities around the state. So,
you know, it's very interesting that's
the approach you take whenever I
actually have lost tremendous amounts of
money since I've been in Congress. And
guess what? That's okay. When I went
into the military, I had nothing as
well. And I'm just proud to be able to
go ahead and serve the American people.
And you can keep trying to play your
foreign policy economic elementary 101,
but the reality is is that I you can't
dispute a single thing that I said about
the economics of oil trade. You can't
dispute a single things about what was
actually benefiting China. You can't do
anything about the belt and road
initiative expansion that I talked
about. So let's talk on the facts as
opposed to ad homonym attacks or some
type of a slanderous point.
>> Did your did your company sell weapons
to Ukraine while you were on the uh
foreign relations committee?
>> No, it didn't actually.
It didn't. There's a lawsuit that claims
that it did. That this is this is not
true. You would have to talk to the CEO
because I can tell you that when I was
there, the only thing that we did was we
worked the US government to help to
defeat ISIS who was in Fallujah and
Mosul who had held that for three plus
years raping and imprisoning young
women, subjugating women and that I'm
very proud of as well as for we supplied
and even at donations to all the
different law enforcement departments
across New York, across Seattle, across
Minneapolis, across New York City,
across Baltimore to stop from the riots
that was going on which everyone in the
Democrat party called the summer of
love. So do you want to talk to your
politics and know about what's actually
happening or go ad hominemum attacks?
>> I just wanted people to understand with
the
>> I also go and buy and sell trade stocks.
By the way, I don't own a single stock
just to so you know unlike many of the
others who actually benefit from
Northrop Breman from GED and from
others. Go look at quantitative analysis
and see how many stocks I've traded
since I've been in office. Go look at
how much I own since I've been in office
and before. I don't own a single penny
of stock. War doesn't benefit me. I
actually prefer not to have war. But the
benefits of actually making sure that we
understand how this looks at it
economically and from a stability and
safety and security perspective. I am
for especially as a member of the
foreign affairs, especially as a proud
US Army combat veteran.
>> Okay, let let me ask Ryan just just
quickly how do you think this war now
plays out from where we are now?
>> I mean, how who knows? Uh I think that
the I think the president is desperate
to find a way to
>> end the war. Uh no, you don't need to be
an expert to see that this is a
catastrophe for the United States. Uh
and it's a catastrophe for the people in
in Thran who are seeing, you know, this
this indiscriminate bombing. There was
just a residential building. People are
chanting people asking for the sha to
come back. You're telling me millions of
people are wrong.
>> People in Lebanon, uh Israel, Israel
issued a an evacuation order to 700,000
people, some of whom, you know, went to
the beach. They then bombed them on the
beach. This is it's the entire situation
is horrifying. When he's talking about,
you know, geopolitics, China is sitting
back watching the way that the United
States military, its navy and its air
force, you know, engage with a with a
conventional military. They're taking
notes as as we exhaust ourselves. Uh I
don't I don't understand who benefits
from this beyond Israel who who wants as
Gideon has said you know to see
countries around it reduced in power and
engaged in kind of sectarian civil war
and collapse.
>> Well let me let me ask Gideon the same
the same question. Gideon what what do
you what do you think is going to happen
here?
First of all, it's very hard to foresee
because finally it depends mainly on
Donald Trump. I still think that if he
wishes to put an end to it, he still
can. Even though I agree to the other
speakers who said that we have reaching
very fast and a point of no return, but
he could have stopped it by now and then
Israel had to stop. Even though by the
time we are talking the Israeli troops
are on the way to Lebanon starting
another war which might last much much
much much longer but Israel does not
benefit out of it. You mentioned all
those who loses Israel never benefit for
any of its wars. If you go backwards
ever since 1948
no war brought any good things to
Israel. They always brought either
immediate losses or losses for the long
run like this fatal 1967 war which stuck
us with this horrible damped occupation
until this very moment. Wars don't serve
interest for the long run and this war
will not serve Israel. Maybe we can all
now sell more weapons. No doubt that
Israel will sell now much more weapons.
We can be very proud on all kind of
James Bond operations, assassinations.
That's a new hobby of Israel,
assassinating half of the leadership of
the Middle East in Hollywood systems.
Really fascinating.
But by the end of the day, after this
all glory will go away. We'll ask
ourself, what did we achieved? What did
we achieve in two and a half years in
Gaza with 70,000 people killed and 1,000
babies killed? What did Israel achieve?
Is it today more secure? Is Gaza more
stable place? Is the danger of Gaza
smaller or bigger for the long run? Same
will be here. And I'm very sorry to say
it because they always say that I always
spoil all those parties. No, it's not a
party. It is a war which gets more and
more complicated and complicates itself
with endless consequences. By the way,
Israel is going also to pay enormous
price in the United States. The
Americans will never forget Israel who
they believe pushed the United States to
this unnecessary war and by the end of
the day will say, "Oh, this was a
mistake." But the next war then will
make it because we have to solve it once
and for all. And the only once and for
all for Israel is the continuence of the
occupation.
>> Good Levy and my panel. Thank you all
very much. I appreciate it.
>> Thank you.
>> Well, I'm joined now by Bethl Talibani.
He's the president of the Patriotic
Union of Kurdistan. Mr. Talibani, thank
you very much indeed for joining me on
Uncensored. Uh, I know you spoke to
President Trump a few days ago. What is
your overview about where we are with
this war right now?
>> Um, first of all, my pleasure to be
here. Um, overview of where we are in
the war so far is you could argue that
many of the US military objectives have
been achieved. Um, severely depleted
ability to strike. um government to an
extent weakened and also I believe
there's no real capability of any kind
of nuclear
um weapon creation. Having said that um
there's still a lot of bombing. Um the
people of Kurdistan are certainly
terrified. Iraq is under a lot of
pressure. You see what's happening in
the Emirates and the Arabic countries
and the Iranian regime doesn't really
show any signs of cracking.
M
>> and also there
>> there's been no real sorry there's been
no real um uprising or demonstration or
even hint thereof until now.
>> Yeah. I mean that's the thing that I've
been looking for which is you know where
is the rising up of the people. Uh you
know there was a belief that maybe the
Kurds were going to lead the the
rebellion and so on. But of course, I'd
imagine that many people, not just the
Kurs, but everyone in the civilian
population has memories of what happened
in January when many thousands of
protesters were killed. Uh, but
secondly, there are bombs raining down
all over the country, and that makes
even venturing onto the street an
extremely dangerous, potentially
life-threatening thing to be doing.
Never mind what the revolutionary guard
or the other militia may do if they find
you there. So it seems to me the
doublepronged threat to to people if
they do take to the streets is very
pronounced right now and the and the
danger is very real.
>> I would agree with that. But I would add
another prong. I think there's three
prongs of concern. Um one of them is the
zip code that um the post code sorry
that the um Iran is in. Um just look at
the recent years. Iran is in the post
code of Afghanistan, Armenia, Syria,
Turkmanistan and Iraq. Um the Persians
are a very well educated, beautiful
people. Um his very old and ancient
people and it's difficult for them to
see them going through what these
countries around them have gone through.
And this is also a real major concern.
In fact, last time a lot of the middle
class and a lot of the professional
class didn't get involved in any of the
demonstrations regardless of their
political view because of this fear.
This fear has not been alleviated at all
and it exists in Iran.
>> If uh as at the moment seems more likely
than not the regime remains in place,
you know, Donald Trump did talk very
early on that he wanted regime change,
but he he made it clear he wanted the
people to lead that. If that doesn't
happen, can the United States
legitimately claim victory?
>> Um, judging by some of the statements
that were made, the initial objectives
militarily, I think some of them have
been achieved. Um, victory for Mr.
Trump, I think you could argue it either
way. My personal opinion is really the
sooner the better. Um don't
underestimate the shock and the damage
the uh assassination of the supreme
leader has had on the psyche of the
country as a whole. Um I think that
shouldn't be underestimated. We're in
danger of this becoming like a wound
from Excalibur. Um a wound that never
heals and I think that should be taken
into account.
There have been reports that Kurdish
armed groups, who of course have fought
the Iranian regime for a very long time,
um, operating from bases along the Iraqi
border, that the reports that the CIA
has been backing some of these groups to
launch ground incursions inside Iran.
Can you say anything about that?
>> I can. Um, this is categorically not the
case, at least in this side of Iraqi
Kurdistan. Um, also please remember the
Kurds make up less than 10% of the
Iranian population of 92 million. Of
that 10% of Kurds, more than 60% of them
are actually Shiite. A lot of them are
in the administrations, they are in the
government, etc., etc. Of that remaining
percentage, how many of them are with
these groups? And what would a Kurdish
attack on Iran do? For example, Turkey
has made it very clear to us that this
is completely unacceptable and they have
their own legitimate concerns. Then you
have the fear of a backlash uh from the
Iranians themselves who are a proud
people and would fear separatism or a
splitting of the country. That's why I
firmly believe Kurds being tip of the
spear is an absolute disaster. And in my
communications with the different
Kurdish groups, I think a lot of them
understand this.
And have you made that clear to
President Trump directly when he spoke
to him?
>> No. The phone call with Mr. Trump didn't
really go there. Um, funny enough, when
I spoke to Mr. Trump, I thought of you
because you often mention the other side
of him that people don't see. And I
really did pick up on that. I picked up
on a genuine caring. I think genuinely
Mr. Trump isn't in favor of war. um he
indicated that he was forced into this
decision and I think that um this is
true and he genuinely seemed to have
caring for Iraq and and for the Kurdish
people and was obviously grateful to us
for the years that we've cooperated
militarily etc etc and the fight against
ISIS and the overthrow of Saddam Hussein
etc.
Well, it's interesting you mentioned
Saddam Hussein because he watched from
his prison cell as your father Jalah
Talibani became the first elected
president of Iraq following the
overthrow of Saddam Hussein. What a
remarkable moment in history that was.
You know, I was editor of the Daily
Mirror newspaper in the UK which took a
very strong position against that war
and for a very long time I felt
thoroughly vindicated. Somebody did say
something interesting this week about
Iraq now. That if you look at Iraq now,
um it is in a much better place now than
it has been for a very long time. And
you could argue that even though it's
been a very tumultuous journey to get to
where it is, that it's been worth the
the pain. Uh what would you say to that?
>> I would agree with that actually. Uh
Pers, I think that that's an an accurate
description. When um Saddam Hussein
forgave everybody in Iraq at one point
except my father. And then when it came
to sign his execution, my father
wouldn't sign it. He said, "There's been
enough blood spilled, but it's taken us
20 years of pitiles combat to get to
today." And it's been a long time. The
Middle East has suffered a lot.
>> Yeah, it has. And it's it's actually
very sad to see uh it all flaring up in
the way that it is now. And I hope
common sense does prevail. Uh Mr.
Talibani, thank you very much indeed for
joining me. I appreciate it.
>> Thank you very much. Thank you.
>> Professor Jang is a game theorist best
known for his popular predictive history
YouTube channel where he applies his
systems of analysis to the past in order
to predict the future. Back in 2024, he
predicted that Trump would win the
presidency, that Trump would go to war
with Iran, and that the US would lose
that war. which has sparked a flurry of
interest in both his work and his rather
colorful adjacent opinions. Professor
Jang joins me now. Professor Jang, thank
you very much indeed for joining me on
Uncensored.
>> Hi, Paris.
>> Let me start with these three big
predictions because you've been proven
uh obviously completely right about two
of them and the third one is now
unfurling before our eyes. Are you
confident that you'll be proven right
with the third prediction that Iran uh
ultimately will prevail in this war?
>> Right. So, right now the United States
and Iran are fighting a war of
attrition. Um the United States is
trying to to degrade Iran's military
capacity. Um and Iran is trying to um
strangle the world economy. And it turns
out that um Iran is putting on a lot of
pressure on the GCC. And I think at the
end of the day um the United States will
be compelled to send ground forces. Once
the United States sends in ground
forces, there's no turning back. It's
all in. Um the sun cost fallacy uh kicks
in. It'll be another Vietnam for the
United States because Iran is a mountain
fortress and uh the United States right
now doesn't have the manpower, the manu
manufacturer capacity and the political
will to fight a long war of attrition on
the ground in Iran.
>> Right. So I think because of what you
said at the end there, it's highly
unlikely that Trump would commit ground
forces because he's always pledged not
to and I think he would see the inherent
danger of that. So, if he doesn't commit
ground forces, how do you see this war
playing out?
>> Well, right now, um, if Trump doesn't
commit ground troops, he does have
variety of options. Um, the first option
is just to simply declare a victory and
call it a day. Uh, unfortunately, the
problem with that is that US bases are
still exposed. The GC economies are
still under pressure. the shumus is
still closed and there are no signs that
Iran is interested in peace
negotiations. Um Iran feels as though it
has the upper hand because it has the
political will um and the resources to
draw this war out. Now let's assume that
Trump does withdraw from uh the Middle
East. Then what happens is that the GCC
uh nations of Saudi Arabia, Ban, uh
Qatar, uh Kuwait, uh UAE now are forced
to pay a ransom to um Iran because uh
they they supply the world with their
oil for the hummus. 20% of the world's
oil flows for the hummus. But in return,
they get food. Um so the GCC nations
import anywhere from 80 80 to 90% of
their food from overseas and so
basically the center of gravity uh
shifts from the petro dollar to whatever
financial system that Iran wants to
wants to focus on and it could be breaks
uh it could be gold it could be anything
but remember the problem with that is
that the US economy is a Ponzi scheme
that's dependent on the GCC investing in
AI
in tech stocks um in uh in startups like
Yuber in order to finance the uh US
economy. If this financing stopped then
the um uh uh US economy could face
collapse and this means that these young
men would could not afford their only
fans anymore and this could lead to a
revolution in the streets. So the the
consequences for America would be dire
if um America were to retreat from the
Middle East.
I mean it seems that the the key part of
all this sort of economic strangulation
if you like by Iran is the straight of
Hormuz. We've already seen uh in the
last few hours today that the uh the
successor to Ayatollah Khmeni his son um
has come out and apparently we haven't
seen him or heard from him directly but
there's a statement in which he talks
about keeping the straight of moose
closed indefinitely. If that was to
happen, what would be the consequences
for the global economy and how soon
would we see those consequences?
Well, I mean, the consequences would be
dire because cheap energy, cheap
petroleum products are the very basis of
the global modern economy. So, it just
wouldn't be jet fuel that be affected.
would also be food because remember food
um um is produced by fertilizer which
comes from the uh GCC as well as
sulfuric acid which which is which helps
the uh process of semiconductor
production. So artificial intelligence
uh food production uh global travel are
all dependent on products from the GCC.
Um it's only been two weeks that uh the
the has been closed for almost two weeks
now and already we're seeing um high oil
prices um surpassing $100 a barrel. Iran
says that they want to move it to $200 a
barrel which signals that they want the
shoo closed for uh months. Now remember
even if Iran were to open up the ship of
humus it would take weeks before oil
production continues. So um I think
we've for the global economy I think
we've reached the point of no return and
and in the future global economies have
to commit to a bit of
de-industrialization
and even mercantalism in order to
survive future shocks. So if you go to
Southeast Asia Vietnam and Thailand have
already ordered the government workers
to work from home in order to save fuel.
you've pointed out that the Gulf
Corporation Council uh monarchies, the
GCC, as you've alluded to several times
here, are structurally unusual states
because they're propped up by oil
desalination. They don't have their own
water supply naturally and American
protection. Uh you say correctly they
were built in open desert with no food
security as you said 80% imported no
water security the desalination
dependency no geographic defenses
they're flat exposed terrain no
demographic cohesion in places like
Dubai for example 90% of the population
are expats and no independent security
architecture reliant on the US who have
bases obviously in many of the states
there if you put all this together is
what's happening now in terms of the
tactics that Iran are deploying uh
including the threat to desalination
um but also targeting obviously it's
targeted hotels and uh and airports and
so on going to the heart of what the
states there would like to see as the
future of their economy which is
tourism, sport, entertainment clearly
designed to to scare people away from
that. Is this now representing an
existential threat do you think to the
business model of the uh GCC uh states
going forward?
>> Right. So the most vulnerable city and
and often the most glamorous city in the
GCC is Dubai. And um for many years
Dubai has been very successful in
cultivating an image as the new city of
London as a new Hong Kong of the Middle
East and thousands of these millionaires
flock to Dubai for the glamorous
lifestyle as well as the tax-free aspect
of the city. But the reality is that um
this was all premised on global peace on
pax american Americana uh on the
capacity of America to project power all
around the world and provide security
guarantees uh to uh the GCC. Now this
aura of inability and invisibility of
American empire has been shattered and
once an illusion is shattered there's
actually no coming back from this and
that's what people don't really
appreciate about this war. This war is
not directed not just directed at
Israel. This war is not directed just at
the GCC and the illusion of of American
empire. This war is directed at American
empire itself. And what people don't
appreciate is the esque esquetological
aspects of this war in that Iran sees um
it sees a moral duty a moral imperative
from God to destroy the great Satan
which is the American empire and the
base of the American empire of course is
the global economy.
>> Right. Um at the at the heart and the
head of the American economy is the
president of the United States. You've
argued that Trump is not the most
powerful person in America. Uh and
you've inferred that actually the real
power base is Israel. Explain that.
>> Right. So I actually don't say the real
power base is um Israel. What I say is
that the real power base are a
collection of secret societies that have
an esquetological view of this war. And
these secret societies include um the
Freemasons which are now called the
Rosacruians and the Knights Templars. Uh
they include um Jewish organizations
called the Sapatine Frankis uh who are
embedded in uh religious movements
called uh Shabet Lupovich. Um and then
you have the Jesuits. you have a
collection of six societies and um they
believe that a war in the Middle East
would start a process that would
culminate in the end times and the
return of Jesus, the arrival of the
Jewish Messiah, um the building of a one
world government. Um they have different
esquetologies, but um a lot of the of
their time frames do align. Um so uh
where they converge is that there has to
be a war in the Middle East to kick
things off. This war in the Middle East
will lead to the defeat of the American
Empire and this will lead to the
culmination of the greater Israel
project where Israel is able to control
the Middle East from the Nile to the to
the Euphrates. Um once the greater
Israel project is in place, it will
transform into into the Pax Judea which
is an AI surveillance state. Um this
will eventually lead to the war of Gog
and Magog, the destruction of the Actric
mosque and the building of the third
temple. uh the return of the Jewish
diaspora to Jerusalem
um and the arrival of the Jewish Messiah
or the Antichrist. So they have the
script scripted out and unfortunately a
lot of world events are conforming to
this script,
>> right? I mean a lot of people say a lot
of what you've just said is a load of
fantastical baloney and driven by uh
anti-semitic tropes. What do you say to
that?
Look, I completely sympathize with this
um argument. Five years ago, I would
have said the same thing about the about
um about this sort of argument and
thinking. So, what I do is predict
predictive modeling. Okay? Meaning that
um I'm going to throw some theories out
there and then based on these theories,
I'm going to extrapolate into the future
and see what the predictions are. If
these predictions are correct, then um
my theories ought to have some
legitimacy. Now when when I teach I
don't engage in historical analysis. I
engage in um speculative uh analysis.
And so in 2024 two years ago I did say
that this war in Iran would happen. And
I provided a lot of my analysis. And a
part of my analysis that's very
important is the esqueological analysis
meaning that Christian Zionists control
the United States. There's there's about
um there's there's a preacher called
John Hegy who uh runs an organization
called Christians United for Israel
which which has about 7 million members.
Um Christian Zionists are heavily
embedded in the uh national security
apparatus and and in the Pentagon uh
there's reporting that uh US commanders
have told their troops that this is a
war to bring back Jesus um and to be not
afraid. So that's my argument like I
don't I don't want to believe this but
because this war in Iran is happening
I'm forced to conclude that some of my
uh speculative analysis uh has validity.
Um otherwise it's
>> well I think I think to be honest yeah I
think the word speculation uh doesn't
quite do it justice. I mean, look,
there's no doubt your predictions so far
have been proven to be uncannily
accurate in relation to Trump winning
and then going to war with Iran. But I
think the idea that uh this is all part
of a plot to bring back Jesus Christ.
Look, there might be some people out
there that carry such a phrase. I think
it's highly unlikely, unless any
evidence emerges to the contrary, that
they are current commanders in the
United States military. Uh but Professor
Jang, you have a big following. Lots of
people are interested in your predictive
analysis and it's good to have you on
our censored. Thank you very much.
>> Thanks be
uncensored is proudly independent. The
only boss around here is me. If you
enjoy our show, we ask for only one
simple thing. Hit subscribe on YouTube
and follow Piers Morgan Uncensored on
Spotify and Apple Podcast. And in
return, we will continue our mission to
inform, irritate, and entertain. And
we'll do it all for free. Independent
uncensored media has never been more
critical and we couldn't do it without
you.